chef David's modern take on North
African cuisine is a lot more
sophisticated the five elements to his
dish required delicate timing and
sous-chef Phillip is getting ahead of
himself don't slice too soon I'm already
know rave chefs not ready don't go yeah
I'll give you 90 seconds before I wonder
laughs come on listen to David Phillips
slow down please don't slice that lamb
too early
yeah when Debbie gives you the call yeah
all in that juice yeah in amongst that
couscous not left on the board yes yeah
please I drove Philip
we can leave it resting here leave it
fat side down like that yeah I always go
do is render and it stay nice and warm
still saying thank you yeah so that one
don't you yes yes well that one down
yes at this stage in competition David
can't afford to make mistakes
Fillie yeah one more over cheap ones I'm
good to mortgagee to get every dish
perfect Momo need to pull together as a
team cuz this yep confident good man
just as well please yes yes yeah like a
proper teamwork good in the middle
saying work off boat race yeah yes
and they've pulled it off baby they look
fantastic very nice of people colors
okay service please
trains up please Table two please yes
fantastic you owe me you'll keep food
speed it's just that musty smoky feel
it's something a bit different we kind
of all agreed that livers not a favorite
thing in the last of Chris's exquisite
tagines are flying out of the kitchen
thank here's just one table to serve
here we are
next up that smells amazing delicious
Gil that was fast it was good next yeah
breathe take some fresh air that's that
one baby yes
my mother service is over and it's time
to find out what my distinguished guests
think about these two extraordinary
dishes starting with a zoo right how is
your lamb shank the lamb Shack was my
favorite it's really soon as I
experienced that source I knew that was
it
authentic and delicious I just enjoyed
it for what it was very simple perfectly
blended I dip the bread in first
mouthful I like them both but I thought
the the mermaid dish was fresh it was
beautifully presented
it was just together delightful I prefer
the zoo dish you could just imagine
yourself being in the old souk
definitely I prefer them in most dish
because me it was very well cooked I'm
used to Moroccan cuisine because I'm
Moroccan myself so it is really a salt
of the tempura liver I was not expecting
it to be quite as mouth-wateringly sort
of whom else from the tongue as it was
it was really really delicious I love
the zoo dish my diners comments
confirmed the brilliance of the food
served here by both the zoo and Momo I'm
happy movement but what made me proud is
we've come together really well
Thank You chef both these teams of
amazing chefs have approached North
African cuisine in very different ways
let's see if the traditional to beat the
modern that's of the partition
now I have an incredibly difficult
decision to make because only one
restaurant can go through the
semi-finals